hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar automated multiplex
immunofluorescence presented by dr.
Bethany remanent and Tracy de Geer I'm
Christie Doyle elaborate and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by Leica Biosystems for more
information on our sponsor please visit
the sponsor tab at the left side of your
screen and click on the logos to be
directed to the sponsor website
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or usually ask a
question box to let us know you're
experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and the
software's continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I would
now like to present today's speakers dr.
Bethany Remnick global application
scientist Akoya Biosciences and Tracy de
Geer director advanced staining
innovation Lika bio systems for complete
biographies on our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen Bethany and Tracy you may now
begin your presentation
Thank You Christy for that introduction
hello everyone my name is Bethany Raman
ik and I am the global application
scientist at a Koya Biosciences today we
will be discussing the advantages of
utilizing Akoya okhla multiplex
immunohistochemistry automated detection
kits on the Leica Biosystems bazar x
auto center to meet your research needs
in addition I will be highlighting some
recommendations to help design your
multiplex panel and optimize your
staining however before we can delve
into this we must first take a step back
to understand how these two platforms
combined help to facilitate a
streamlined workflow and drive cancer
research forward from 1991 to 2015
cancer deaths in the United States alone
fell by 26% this is due in part to
significant advances in the treatment of
cancer patients including the use of
more personalized therapies for
individuals as well as fda-approved
immunotherapy treatments such as anti
pd-1 and anti PDL one however not all
individuals who test positive for these
markers will respond to targeted
treatment
help understand why we may have
responders and non-responders we must
first acknowledge that the biology and
composition of the tumor
microenvironment is very complex there
are several specialized cell types
including immunity the cells such as
macrophages and B and t-cell lymphocytes
but interact directly and indirectly
with tumor cells resulting in an ever
evolving relationship between immune
cells trying to destroy the tumor cells
while simultaneously the tumor cells
attempting to evade and promote their
own self growth because of this there
are several influencing factors that
need to be taken into consideration when
interrogating the tumor micro
environment including cellular
phenotypes that can influence the
biology of the tumor the functional
status of the surrounding cell types as
well as other contributing factors such
as inflammatory mediators and how they
all interact within the spacial biology
of a tumor microenvironment having a
greater understanding of the
relationships happening within the tumor
microenvironment are key to improving
diagnosis and designing new therapeutic
regimens
currently clinical laboratory tests are
automated and performed by calibrated
machines to reduce human err however in
the majority of anatomic pathology and
disease diagnosis is still based upon
physician interpretation of microscopic
tissue characteristics such as cells
markers and tissue architecture in fact
this visual assessment using
conventional that the chemistry remains
the gold standard for cancer diagnosis
despite this it is recognized that
visual assessment can be subjective and
interpretation of results we prefer
between pathologist additionally because
I'm unit has the chemistry such as dab
can only be conducted for a single
marker on tissue samples very little
information can be obtained about the
spatial context and interplay of other
cellular phenotypes within the tumor
microenvironment
on the other hand genomics and
proteomics studies including flow
cytometry and DNA microarrays provide
significant quantitative information
regarding different cellular phenotypes
within the tumor
however the spatial context law as
analysis needs to be conducted using
homogenized tissue is thus we're at this
crossroads been in where on one platform
we were able to retain morphology but
lose phenotypic information or
conversely have a wealth of phenotype
data but lose spatial biology and
interactions between them
in order to advance research forward we
need to be able to retain a spatial
biology of the tumor microenvironment
while simultaneously identifying and
labeling multiple markers of interest
and this is where immunofluorescence is
truly able to bridge the divide
immunofluorescence overcomes the
limitations with conventional
immunohistochemistry which are
constrained by detecting two or three
markers of interest by allowing for
multiplexing of several markers by using
this methodology researchers are able to
conserve their tissue samples while
identifying and characterizing cellular
interactions immunofluorescence and then
identify and reveal weak expresser that
may be lost using conventional and used
needed hits the chemistry staining and
furthermore the balancing of signal can
allow researchers to detect multiple
markers that co-localize from the same
cell lastly immunofluorescence can
provide better signal for quantification
and data analysis
hmm
while there are many benefits associated
with immunofluorescence there are
challenges with conventional
methodologies that can unfortunately
limit your staining success first Danny
will need to be done using antibodies
raised in different species a secondary
antibodies may cross react and ruin your
results this unfortunately can be
sticking as some rare antibodies may
only be raised in one species next
damage ins may be sheltered from a
primary antibody due to steric hindrance
furthermore signals can be unbalanced or
low if you have an overabundance of a
marker or very little expression of
another other factors that may impact
your results include background staining
attributing tissue autofluorescence
which can be a result of the tissue
itself as well as how the tissue was
processed and photo bleaching or
quenching of the floor fourth if they
are exposed to light
thus the Opel fluorophores were created
to overcome the limitations of
conventional immunofluorescence as part
of the Synoptics workflow Opel dyes are
accessible to anyone who has previously
worked with standard
immunohistochemistry Opel allows for
detection of multiple cellular
phenotypes to be visualized and
quantified simultaneously in the same
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded tissue
section enabling researchers to study
the complex relationships and
distribution of these cells while
retaining spatial context within the
tumor microenvironment with Opel you can
select any primary antibody wish for
immunity to chemistry detection based
upon their performance rather than being
relegated to a species type and lastly
local small T clicks assays and kits
provide a practical workflow that allows
for the simultaneous detection of
upwards of eight biomarkers of interest
plus that be nuclear counterstain within
a single tissue section
Okoye offers Opel automated ihd
detection kits for research to perform
Opel multiplex staining on one of the
leading research automated dating
platforms the bond rx by like a biases
them automation provides you with the
flexibility to support the dynamic
demands of translational research open
platform promotes a simplified workflow
that frees up users time for other
research endeavors high throughput Opel
bond protocols can perform upwards of
seven color immunofluorescence staining
on 30 slides which can be performed
overnight as opposed to typically
running manually which may take two to
three days
and lastly automation can achieve
quality consistency and reproducibility
with every sample and support the
transition into clinical studies
but how does one actually go about
staining with opal using the bond rx
well it's previously mentioned opal guys
allow for the use of any standard
unlabeled primary antibody including
multiple antibodies raised in the same
species here we have a microscope slide
that has been bar coded to recognize to
be recognized by the bonds are ex
after introduction of the primary
antibody the Opel polymer HRP is applied
the Opel system then uses pyramide
signal amplification or TSA to amplify
IHC detection by covalently depositing
multiple floors near the targeted
antigen after labeling is complete
antibodies are removed in a manner that
does not disrupt the Opel fluorescent
signal allowed for the next target to be
detected without antibody
cross-reactivity these steps are
repeated for all markers of interest the
Opel technology thus enables development
of multiplex assays with balanced
quantitative signal for both rare and
abundant targets of interest
moving forward we wanted to test the
stability and reproducibility of opal on
the bond rx first to confirm
fluorescence the signal stability of the
opal dies on the bond rx we conducted a
series of repeated stripping steps with
each opal for four and determined over
the course of six repeated high
intensity epitope retrievals but the
opal dive signal remains stable for all
floors including our classic six fours
that we have and our latest additional
floors including the opal Polaris for
Andy
next in to demonstrate opals ability to
detect markers in the same player
compartments without interference from
TSA deposition then we stay in console
with both cd3 and cd8 as they are often
found in close proximity with one
another on the same cell on the Left we
have a merged overlay of cd3 and cd8
channels where signal overlap appears in
white and then we have the individual
channels appearing to the right as you
can see TSA does not interfere with the
detection of co-localization of markers
of interest
next we wanted to test the consistency
and reproducibility of the bond rx
ad stating Gopal here we ran mono plexus
staining for CD 20 using oval 520 on
serial sections of possible for all 30
slide positions we demonstrate that
slide variability between all 30 slides
for a Purcell expression of CD twenty
produce a coefficient of variation less
than 5% indicating that the bond is able
to produce consistent and reliable
staining results
for the next testing procedure we assess
upon their accessibility to reliably
staying 15 console serial sections for a
seven color multiplex panel for each of
the open floor fours we analyze the mean
counts of the top twenty brightest tiles
per slide and found that for each marker
there was a calculated CV of 14% or less
which given the nature of serial
sections speaks to the consistency of
both opal staining as well as the
functionality reliability of the bond
are acts in producing consistent results
for all your standing needs
mm next we're going to delve into some
tick tips tricks and recommendations to
help optimize your opal staining here on
the Left we have an overview of how
staining is run on the bond rx using the
newest opal Polaris immune hit the
chemistry automated detection kit which
includes our newest fluorophores the
opal Polaris 480 and the opal Polaris
780 local protocols are auto populated
on the bond rx and can be used as they
are for all of our other kits that we
have however if you wish to do staining
with the opal Polaris the opal Polaris
kits you will need to modify that
protocol to include opal or 780
at the end of the staining run and at
the end of this presentation as well I
will also share some additional standing
resources to help support your staining
endeavors
hmm well first we have some
recommendations from Akoya to help in
your mana Plex development first we
recommend that you use tonsil to
optimize all of your mana flexes and
this is ideal because council has a
number of markers of interests that are
highly expressed making an ideal to help
optimize your primary antibody dilution
we recommend going ahead with a series
of 3 d a.b titration and then optimizing
from there based on staining pattern and
intensity once you feel you've optimized
your primary antibody Lucian using da da
we recommend then converting it to
immunofluorescence
here then you would want to pick an
ideal opal pairing to go with the
primary antibody and some factors to
consider include a CO expression so if
you happen to be looking at multiple
markers of interest on the same cellular
compartment you might want to choose an
opal pairing that for that primary
antibody that is perhaps a little bit
far removed from the other marker of
interest that you are looking to image
for example you may want to choose opal
520 pair 2 CD 3 and then maybe opal 5 7
your opal 622 look at CD 8 furthermore
you also want to take into consideration
whether or not you are investigating
rare versus abundant markers if you are
looking at markers that may not be
highly expressed or weak expresses you
may want to pair them with an oval that
is very bright in this case opal players
480 or opal 520 versus if you happen to
have a blended mark of interest such as
cytokeratin you may want to pair that
with some of the more lower bright opal
eyes including opal 619 opal or a 7th
meeting
for opal concentrations we recommend
starting at 1 to 150 dilution and then
titrating up or down as needed because
we like you to remain with an already
predetermined primary antibody dilution
next you'll want to go ahead and assess
your target brightness and we recommend
that target target brightness counts
follows at a range of ten to thirty with
the exception of opal Polaris 780
because it is near the infrared we
recommend that you target anywhere from
a range of one to ten this can be done
using our one platform which is free its
fee no charge and you can go ahead and
then look at the normalized counts and
then you can adjust your opal titration
from there once you get done optimizing
your console multiplexes we recommend
transitioning those dilution factors
onto project tissue samples and
reoptimize is needed and again we
recommend not really adjusting the
primary gun upon a dilution factor and
trying to titrate out your opal
next for each project a coined that you
create a new library slide set to ensure
you obtain the best floor for spectrum
to extract from mixing if you are using
a Synoptics imaging system to achieve
the best results we recommend using
chemical once again and standing forward
cd20 as it is ubiquitous uniform and it
is highly expressing you will want to
stay in one slide for each floor for
along with one slide for dabbing in
addition you will want to create an auto
fluorescent slide but this you will want
to use tissue that is representative of
your project as all the fluorescence is
not the same amongst tissue types and
using Council for this may not reflect
the amount of autofluorescence that your
project tissue samples may have
lastly once you have optimized your mana
plexes it is time to pull everything
together and staying in a multiplex now
here you want to consider in particular
staining order when staining you want to
take into consideration antigen
retrieval as certain antigens can become
more exposed after a repeated round of
antigen retrieval and these include PDL
1 and ki-67 which you may want to have
later in your staining order conversely
there are other imogen that you may want
to put at the beginning of your staining
order because they may become more
degraded as you have repeated exposure
to antigen retrieval next you also want
to take into consideration the biology
as well some floor for intensity can be
attenuated after multiple antigen
retrievals including opal 520 and opal
570 but as you saw on the earlier slide
over all those signal intensity remains
consistent throughout the staining but
it is something to take into
consideration
lastly for image acquisition you'll want
to go ahead and consult the instrument
handbook or user manual that came with
your respective platform when wanting to
image your multiplex panel
I've been mentioned earlier for more
information pertaining to designing and
optimize your opal staining on the Leica
Biosystems bond rx please use the opal
multiplex
IHC assay development guide which can be
found on a Koya bio.com there will
actually be a new updated version coming
out in the next few months so be sure to
keep an eye out for it when it does
happen in addition under the resources
section of our website we also provide
three opal multiplex automated protocols
that utilize the like upon R X and then
lastly our European applications and
development leader Virginia Zuba gave a
great online tutorial that delve step by
step into the opal multiplex IHC
optimization process so if you have any
other questions please feel free to go
ahead and utilize these resources
in summary we have demonstrated that the
bond Rx really does provide a
reproducible consistent and fully
automated workflow that works
harmoniously with opal and opal itself
allows for the detection of upwards of
nine colors of interest on a single
tissue section so this flexible system
together really does allow users to
design their own panel use their own
validated antibodies and then running on
the Lego Biosystems bond rx you're able
to facilitate high-throughput research
in the clinical setting
so thank you all so much for your time
and if you have any additional questions
please feel free to reach out to our
customer care at Akoya bio comm
I'll hand it off to Tracy now
thank you so much Bethany
my name is Tracy de Geer and I am the
director of innovation for like Avaya
systems advanced training units and I'm
going to speak to you just a little bit
about the bond direct instrument that
you heard Bethany and talk about that is
used in conjunction with the Opel kits
that are produced by a Koya and fall
under the Synoptics group and one of the
things that is unique about the bond Rx
is that it is a fully dedicated research
platform and the things that makes it so
amenable to being used in research and
in tamarka tting with products like a
coil and maple is that the software has
a lot of unique capabilities for
openness so one is the thing that makes
it
so easy to use is that it gives
researchers the ability to explore ideas
and you can run lots of different types
of testing based off of the openness of
the software and you can accelerate
testing programs because the three doors
on the instrument function almost like
three separate painters and that allows
you to not only run kits like the April
but also do some of your routine
research work if you'd like to do that
and as you've seen with what Bethany's
group at a Koya have been able to do and
they were able to actually commercialize
a very wonderful and unique idea with us
so we're going to talk just briefly
about some of the unique features and
the Explorer idea is one of the things
that really attracts groups like a Koya
and like it together and that's one of
the things that makes our relationship
so wonderful is that we're able to
automate so many different types of
tests in the research lab and that helps
us advance the treatment of cancer and
other diseases in the research world
um so if you're you're looking to do
research then you can do wonderful a
face like the April on the
instrumentation if you're looking to
develop something on your own there's
always that unique spot where your chest
can fit in
based on the things that you can do and
there is a long history of being able to
run tissue based assays on the like of
on platforms like a-- has been around
for over 50 years in an anatomic
pathology and so one of the things that
if the hallmark of that is their
tradition of quality instrumentation
microsomes
all the way through this is a little bit
about the technology online of the bond
instrumentation itself the bond rx has
not been around quite as long as some of
the bond platforms it actually did not
come into being until 2012 and and that
if you look at the theme of some of the
instrumentation that's been on the
market is not very long so the
instrument was released in 2011 and then
immediately there was this desire to
start making the software into something
very very unique
um the Akoya group was actually our
second marketing partner that came on
board with our open innovation team and
has been a strong partner for us ever
since and they we started with them when
they were still with PerkinElmer
and have built a very strong
relationship with him all along and
that's allowed us to bring some of the
wonderful testing that we've been able
to bring to you through that unique
partnership
if you look at all of the possibilities
that you're allowed to do or we enable
as a team for you to do on the
instrument you can do multiplex
fluorescents you can do into
hybridization you can do
immunohistochemistry ln A's mRNA all of
those things or possibilities within the
instrumentation itself
last year one of the things that came
about with the bond rx was the release
of the 6.0 software that gave
researchers a greater capability in what
can be accessed and done with this
software itself there are a lot of
things that the software has always said
you had a lot of freedom to explore
those things one of the goals of the
team has always been to increase that
capability there's additional pre
staining capabilities now there are
additional customizations that you can
make in order to control some of the
things that we used to have to send
filled service representatives and to do
for you and so you have that greater
flexibility to do those things yourself
now without having to wait on us and
that was one of the things that we were
very excited to bring out
the priest singing lets you adjust times
and temperatures a little bit more you
can add and subtract alcohol steps
tissues are not always created equally
that was one of the things that through
the years and experiences the team came
to realize and so sometimes it can't be
created it can't be treated equally and
then gave greater optimization for our
users to be able to adjust to those
conditions within their own life or even
the tissues that come in from other
places because sometimes if you're
working on research studies you can't
control what comes into the laboratory
and so this day that added bit of
flexibility to those pieces and there's
also the ability to change incubation
times and temperatures for antibodies
for in steps all of those types of
things
applications for probes and antibodies
all of those pieces have evolved over
the time and the life of the
instrumentation itself one of the unique
features that was really exciting for us
was the defense type that's something we
used to have to send either application
specialists or engineers and to adjust
for either our partners like the Koya or
even our customers who work in the lab
research laboratories every day and it
was something unique they wanted to do
and it required either an F in defense
or it required a different type of
dispensing than what was installed when
the instrument left the factory and we
would have to send someone then to
adjust that for them the instrument
allows the researcher to adjust that on
their own now so they can actually
experiment a little bit more and change
those things on their own and that gives
a little bit better adaptability for the
instrumentation without them feeling
constrained to wait on this to be able
to get put into their laboratory to make
those adjustments for them
an in the same intestine ization and you
can determine what ever type of
incubations you need you can change
things for the washes you can actually
change things for a variety of multiplex
protocols and that allows for greater
optimization on the part of the
researcher would like for the
instruments to be able to bend to the
will of the researcher rather than the
researcher bending to the wheel of a
piece of instrumentation that's always
been the goal
with those goals it allows people to
accelerate their testing programs and
the reason that such a wonderful thing
is it gives you more opportunities to
actually test more if you have multiple
groups working in the laboratory then
your instrument with the doors can
actually give you more opportunities to
put more teams on the instrument if you
don't want to start off three doors at
the same time then that works great the
instrument can be very quick depending
on what you're running and if you're
running a nine flex then as Bethany said
that will probably be an overnight run
for you and we do have other assays that
are overnight run but basic IHC can be
very quick spending on the needs of the
laboratory itself it's very efficient
and one of the things that it will do is
it depending on the version of the
instrument that you have it will tell
you when fluids are low you can do your
visual management from across the
laboratory and not have to sit in and
babysit the instruments the openness of
the containers and you can set up
titration vials and let the instrument
do your titration stories you don't have
to come back and take care of that on
your own you can run open detection
there is added flexibility coming in the
eyes and detection this year so there'll
be some unique things coming down the
pipe that we're hoping will be out by
the end of the year hopefully if not by
the 1st of next year
the visual management of the instrument
is very nice you can see everything on
the front screen which lets you from
across the room while you're carrying on
important tasks in your laboratory be
able to look at a glance and see what's
going on with your instruments and if
there are things you want to add or
remove or take care of then you can do
that thing looks like
the bulk fluids changed to allow them to
be part of that visual management as
well and customers have found that they
very much like those pieces
now I came from another company and one
of the things that we used to pick on
quite a bit was the cover tile now that
I have joined innovation I have actually
found that the cover clouds are a very
unique piece of what we do they provide
a lot of safety and security to the
tissues on the the clients themselves
and allow for some of the unique
partners that we've been able to form in
innovation they actually provide a lot
of safety and security to everything
that goes on to the slide and that has
enabled us to form some of the unique
partnerships that we've been able to
form and as we move forward on the
bomber x you're going to see some very
very unique partnerships come out of
this the ability that we are and we do
use the cover slips cover tiles that we
use and they are a very wonderful piece
of what we do the April assay actually
works excellent with the cover tiles
that we have on there and it helps us do
a lot of long a phase when you look at
the overnight piece and get good
staining with those and protect our
tissues at the same time
we have a lot of wonderful partners that
we work with and all of those have come
about based off of the relationships
that we were able to build with our
first partners which were a CD and the
acquire group so if it hadn't been for
them than it would have been very
difficult for us to move forward and
build some of the partnerships that
we've got today
so Oya is a strong partner for us their
technology has been a wonderful addition
to the research world and continues to
grow and expand across the globe and is
a wonderful asset to the research world
as the micro environment becomes more
and more important to cancer research
it's very important for all of us to be
able to be a little bit further into the
tissue and the special relationships
that we get between the cells and this
has helped drive
so the research world and our own look
into these into the micro environment
as we're looking at multiplexing you
also see a lot of the ctc world going
that same direction you will see them
multiplexing with fluorescents as well
and one of our partners is also in the
CTC world and you notice that they use
many of the same types of colors that
you will find from a Koya these are
different types of cells and not as not
tissue based but the circulating tumor
cell world also means very heavily on
the fluorescence
you do see a lot going on in the
multiplexing world this is another of
our key marketing partners this is all
TV and they also do multiplexing
and our other long-term partner that we
have worked with for a very long time as
a CD and a lot of what we do in the
innovation for the bond rx came up on
the backs of both a CD and a coil and a
CD is our mRNA partner and they have
launched several different several
different types of products with us just
like Sequoia has and with the mRNA they
are our longest list partner and they
actually our first partner to go from
the research world into the clinical
space that's where the commercialize our
discovery paste comes from one of the
things as a researcher that is very
unique is the fact that when you run on
the bond rx you use the same software
that both the Koya and ACD and the other
partners run on their instrumentation so
with the open detection kit and the
ability to run the engine software and
create an assay in your laboratory that
has the ability to change how people
view medicine or how people treat cancer
those technologies that you use in your
lab are the exact same that all of our
partnerships so the things that make
that unique are the ability to whatever
you need to put into those open
detection miles the ability to customize
your protocols however you would like to
customize them but at the same time you
get the standardization of using a
routine box Luud rich in image and
retrieval and you get the run to run
consistency that Bethany showed you when
she went through her procedures that
they tested for the opal products and
that gives you a combination of
flexibility but the consistency that you
would want if you were going to publish
or if you were going to develop
something on your own that you
eventually wanted to show
so it's that combination of the two that
makes the partnerships you need
so it creates a pathway from the
instrument to partnership like a Koya to
eventually something that maybe someday
we'll see in the clinic and those are
the things that all of us who work in
cancer research are hoping to someday
see
but that's the path that our partners
have taken and hopefully that maybe you
will see and something that you do that
we're proud to call Akoya partner and I
hope that you find value and what we do
together and if you have any questions
at all please reach out to either your
cell trap at Laika or please reach out
to a Koya if we can answer any questions
at all for us and let us know if there's
anything at all that we can do to help
you thank you so much for your time and
I'm going to hand the mic back for open
questions
Thank You Tracy and Bethany for your
presentations and it is now time for our
live Q&A portion of our webinar if you
have a question you would like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen as a reminder any questions
that we are not able to answer alive
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period Bethany and Tracy will
be answering them via email to the
address you provided at the time of
registration okay let's get started
Stephanie let's start with you how about
this question how long does ask a
development typically typically take for
ople on the bond
that's a really great question so
typically we would say that with our
support and you know following the steps
that we provide as well as what Leica
provides
typically accurately we would say that
between determining antibody order and
pairing running through the mono plexus
and then transitioning to a multiplex we
say that for your first panel it would
be about a month you know that can of
course vary depending on the markers of
interest as well and if you know you
have variability within your staining
pattern however we average about a month
for a new panel
take you Bethany tricky let's pop over
to you how long does the sixth flex
essay take on the bond rx cake from
beginning to end
so that's an excellent question so if
you look in the literature of the six
flex si plus the Daffy and take up to
about 14 hours and this is once the
assay has been fully optimized and
that's why the recommendation is that if
you're going to run the full f8 that you
run it overnight
Thank You Tracy Stephanie must come over
you can i dilute out my primaries since
opal amplified signals so much great
question so as mentioned in the
presentation we typically recommend that
you try to titrate your opal up or down
pending you know on what signal you want
to achieve but sometimes when you
transition from a tonsil mono Plex to
your tissue of your project mana Plex
that you know sometimes there can be
discrepancy that titrating opal can
account for so during this instance we
would recommend actually either
titrating your primary antibody then you
know for example like if it's cd8
staining you know it'll be a very strong
and intense so in that circumstance you
would want to perhaps they loot out more
your primary antibody but we would try
to recommend trying the opal titration
first before taking a step back to
dilute your primary
Thank You Bethany now we have some great
questions coming in and we have time for
just a few more Tracy do you always need
to run a six Plex essay on the bond rx
or can you run up to a six flex
depending on your needs as a researcher
that's a great question and you do not
always have to run a six pack and if you
wanted to structure your assay so that
you're running a three flex or a four
flex depending on your needs as a
researcher you can actually adapt that
to your own need it is not necessarily
that you want that you have to always
run at six flex per se you can you can
structure that order however you would
like to do that and then determine the
best colors to suit your needs
Thank You Tracy and Bethany will wrap
with this final question when
interrogating co-localize markers does
it matter what order I applied them in
yes these questions are really great so
for example in the example I showed CD 3
and cd8 it does matter sometimes what
order you apply them in because in
particular if they're on the same
cellular compartment there could be
differences in expression level and so
we typically recommend that when you are
interrogating co-localize markers that
you want to put the lower expressing
markers first and then have the higher
expressing ones afterwards but really
what you want to do is you will want to
look at the staining pattern expression
and assess from there if you realize
that when you sing one way say CD 3 and
then CD 8 that you aren't getting
consistent expression of one of the
markers try flipping them and seeing if
that will make a difference and
typically it will but for the most part
we haven't really seen too much issue
with these but once again an excellent
question and if anybody else would like
more information on that please feel
free to reach out
Thank You Bethany and Thank You Tracy
I'd also like to thank our audience for
joining us and for their interesting
questions and as a reminder those
questions we did not have time to answer
today and those committed during the on
demand period will be addressed by our
speakers via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration on
I'd like to once again thank dr. Bethany
reminisce and Tracy to here for their
time today and their excellent
presentations we'd also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor like a
Biosystems for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand and laborat will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event that's all for
now and we hope to see you again soon